and public policy events in Washington
DC and around the country c-span is
brought to you by your cable or
satellite provider
Washington Journal continues Ronald
Kessler joining us about his latest book
the Trump Whitehouse changing the rules
of the game good morning to you good to
be here
talk about this idea of the rules that
are already in place and what Donald
Trump has brought as far as change well
obviously he's changing almost
everything he's he's standing up to
countries like Syria by sending missiles
in he is see regulating so that the
stock market has been booming the
unemployment rate is at record low
levels including the black unemployment
rate
he has gone after Isis removed the
shackles on the military to almost
totally destroy Isis got Saudi Arabia to
go after radical Islamic terrorism so if
you look at the big picture it is very
very impressive and I say he's gonna be
seen as one of the greatest presidents
just like Reagan who was also reviled by
the media but yet got rid of the Soviet
Union and got the economy going at the
same time the book is a truthful account
that tells it like it is it has lots of
negative items juicy tidbits and it
explains who this guy is and that is the
hardest task of all as you can imagine
and the prologue to this you wrote this
thing but beyond the outrageous comments
and tweeting beyond the infighting and
dimension there was another story that
the media largely ignored sweeping
presidential action that indeed was
making America great again never before
as an American president had so much
impact on the country and a world so
short a time as Donald Trump yeah can
you write that and still look
objectively at the president oh yeah you
know if you're an honest journalist you
can do that although there were a few
honest journalists left anymore this is
really the first truthful book on Trump
and his presidency as opposed to what I
call a novel which was the Michael Wolf
book almost totally fiction so much of
it obviously fiction you know Melania
was in tears on election night Donald
Trump looked like a ghost because he
never wanted to be president just absurd
and what this book does is as dozens of
new items that you never knew about
Trump and one reason you never knew is
that he doesn't want anybody to know he
likes to have a mask over his face and
project this tough-guy image so for
example the
fact that he hands out hundred-dollar
bills to janitors from when they move
furniture it doesn't like to hear about
it doesn't want people know about that
when I interviewed him at merrill ago
and it's the only interview he's given
for a book and I asked him about that
and he sort of obfuscated well where'd
you hear that how do you know that he
just cannot stand to have anything
personal out the same with the fact that
Milania is a very powerful force I quote
Reince Priebus on the record as saying
that her judgment is impeccable she sits
in on meetings she contributes strategy
never came out before and again she's
derided in the press as a fool and an
idiot even though she speaks six
languages and so I just separate the
myth from the reality there's a picture
of you when your wife wit Donald Trump
how long have you known President Trump
I've known him and Melania for two
decades I first got to know him when I
flew down with my wife Pam also former
Washington Post reporter to do a book on
Palm Beach I call it my midlife crisis I
had to drink more champagne and go to
more parties and on the way down he
imitated the nasal constricted tones of
the Blue Bloods the old guard in Palm
Beach condemned in his club maril ago
because it admits Blacks and Jews to
this day there are some clubs in Palm
Beach that do not admit that Blacks and
Jews and he said to me I want to be
loved and I enjoy a stick staining
sticking it to them and that's exactly
what he's all about he wants to be loved
but he enjoys sticking it to anybody who
gets in his way
you said you sat down with the president
for this interview what other sources do
you have within the White House for this
book I really had unprecedented access
and combined the interview which is he's
never done for a book knowing him for
two decades and interviewing a lot of
the key people the people are actually
in the Oval Office and you can see many
of them on the record others are not but
it is the real story and I think people
will be amazed to find the real truth
about things and one one amazing thing
is just a Washington Post door that I
eyesight August 14th of last year which
quoted emails turned over by
Whitehouse to congressional committees
in which Manafort the campaign chairman
says no we don't we don't want to go to
Russia we have to warn Trump not to do
anything with Russia his his deputy says
the same thing mana furred assigned
someone to make sure no one follows up
on this proposal by Papadopoulos to go
to Russia and meet with Russian leaders
what morning needs to know about Russian
collusion at the same time I take the
side of the FBI on some issues for
example why Hillary was not indicted
explained why the law would not support
that unless there was real show of
criminal intent and so I think that case
was a major saying the reason she was
not indicted is that that's right there
was no evidence of criminal intent as
there was with other people where the
FBI was able to charge them with liens
the FBI and therefore show criminal
intent so our guest will be with us for
the half hour if you want to ask him
questions about his book and the things
that he found out in interviewing
President Trump and other people again
202 some 488 thousand won for
Republicans 202 semper 88,000 for
Democrats to or to semper 88,000 to for
independence mr. Castle you talked about
those two phases so to speak of Donald
Trump talk about the public faces
particularly his style of management
much has been made about how he conducts
his White House particularly the inside
and with his closest advisors how would
you describe that well he is his own
chief of staff and he constantly
canvasses people for opinions his
advisors but also about a dozen friends
most of them billionaires that list in
the book as well as just chamber maids
and Secret Service agents you know
there's a reason why they're working
class voted for him and that is that he
appreciates their common sense so you
know to try to pigeonhole someone who
has great influence besides Melania it
is is really fruitless I quote Norma
Ford or in the book she was the top aide
to Trump for 26 years when she joined
the Trump Organization it only had seven
other employees and she says there are
two Donald Trump's one is the one you
see on TV who makes these outrageous
comment
to get attention for his brand and now
for his presidency so it's a strategy
and then there's the real Donald that
only insiders now who's just the
opposite he's thoughtful he listens he's
careful when he makes his decisions he
didn't build this Empire worth billions
of dollars by being a fool an idiot or a
bigot and what's the takeaway though
with the the rash of people leaving the
White House of wave you tilite brains
Priebus you talk about Steve ban and
some days he's okay with Jeff Sessions
yesterday he criticizes Jeff Sessions
how does all those play into how a white
house is conducted yeah and by the way I
explain why sessions is doing a great
job
you know chump has this this habit of
just blowing up when when he doesn't
like something and one example is when
back at merrill ago martha stewart
showed up and tony Senecal the butler at
merrill ago opened the door and and she
said could i take it to her merrill ago
and tony said sure we'll set it up for
three o'clock tomorrow and then he told
Donald Donald said fine later in the day
Trump was in the private quarters tony
checked with him to see if there's
anything he needs and Trump started
screaming at him you son of a [ __ ] you
you dumb ass you you should have
scheduled it for noon tomorrow because
then Martha would see the the club
members and the club members would see
Martha at that moment Melania walked in
and she said I don't think you should be
talking to Tony in that tone so that
tells you that she will disagree with
Trump and and provide her wisdom and
nothing more was said but then the next
morning they were both Tony and Trump
were in the living room of merrill ago
and Trump handed Tony two thousand
dollars in cash and $20 bills would you
believe that was his apology and I asked
Tony me wasn't that strange that he
offered the money in $20 bills and Tony
said everything about mr. Trump is
strange the book is again the Trump
White House changing the rules of the
game authored by Ronald Kessler joining
us for this conversation and your phone
calls our first call for you comes from
Earl and Earl is in Arlington Texas
independent line you're on with Ronald
Kessler good morning go ahead
okay I'm just gonna jump right in
there's not one executive order or
specific bill that's been passed to
target directly african-american
unemployment rate he has nothing to do
with that battle Trump I'm referring to
number two he himself referred to the
unemployment rate as a con during the
Obama administration instead of the
railway with more like 30 percent it has
not been calculated any different it's
just some of us a double standard
because now he's saying three he did not
destroy Isis they had 15,000 members in
Isis they were fighting against four
different countries
he himself had nothing to do with that
it was just sheer time and we'll of the
other people to get rid of Isis for okay
you name any can you name any policy he
changed for the military - Singh as the
rules of engagement and I would like to
hear your answer thank you
okay sure well first of all on the
unemployment rate and have the reason
that is at historic lows lower than any
point in recorded history is that Trump
is deregulating and none of that has
excuse me made of CEOs I don't feel if
they can expand and hire more people and
that's also where the stock market is up
40 percent since the election a lot of
this is psychological people feel they
can they can invest that businesses are
not going to be demonized the way they
were under under Obama now into all the
details of military engagement and how
he removed restrictions you know that
that's in the book I quote people like
HR McMaster whom I interviewed so you
know you can either believe that or not
you know people just have blinders on
they can't possibly comprehend that this
person who does make rages comments and
certainly does make up stores could
actually produce solid results but the
results are very obvious if you if you
read the newspapers in Ronda from New
Jersey Democrats line your arm with
Ronald Kessler go ahead Good Morning
America and boy do I love my country I'm
just calling to say that
I want to give a shout out to Melania
Trump for rising above all the gossip in
the media and I really wish we would cut
this out I am so sick of Muller I'm
tired of them overwhelming our president
when we have so much to do to fix in
this country I'm angry at Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell for not coming out and
assisting this man in an office the most
powerful office in the world and they
are totally silent it's enough you know
the people in the south don't know Trump
we in New Jersey New York area we always
knew Trump he was always a Playboy when
he was a younger man but this man is a
genius and if we allow him to put a
vision forward for this country to
rebuild our infrastructure no one will
ever be able to even come near the
United States Robert McDonough thank you
you mentioned roller that was a result
of Jared and Ivanka urging Trump to fire
Jim Comey as FBI director and that of
course led to the appointment of a
special counsel and when I interviewed
Trump at merrill ago he asked me what I
said think of Muller I've interviewed
him many times I've written three books
on the FBI one of which led to the
dismissal of William sessions over his
abuses and I said he's a man of
integrity he's turned around the FBI to
make it more prevention-oriented that's
why we we have not had a successful
foreign terrorist attack by foreign
terrorist network and he appreciated
that you know behind the scenes he
actually does listen and is is is
totally common and in command so that is
my take on Muller and I think you know
eventually he's going to finish his
investigation I think he's wrapping it
up and and he's going to find no
collision as I cited that Washington
Post story making it clear the campaign
wanted nothing to do with Russians two
quick things that the FBI's actions with
the lawyer Michael Cohen and concerns
about attorney-client privileges what's
the case there I think there's there's
something there and I'll tell you
White House aides have never been
impressed by my Michael Cohen they feel
that he's an embarrassment when he gets
on TV and starts you know aggressively
attacking the host this is obviously a
separate investigation it was approved
by the acting US attorney in New York
who was a trumpet appointee sessions as
a trump appointee it's very hard to turn
all that around and assume that this is
some kind of witch hunt certainly
there's a witch-hunt against Trump
in the media in general you know I've
been interviewed by mainstream reporters
for this book the Trump White House and
and they just can't contain themselves
they have to snicker and and make Joseph
comments
whenever I say anything positive about
Trump that's their way of communicating
the caller had brought up his playboy
past and that's what she used when you
hear stories that about stormy dangers
do you think those are legitimate
concerns to be explored or is that a
distraction in your mind well it's
obviously a story I think it's important
to keep in mind that these activities
occurred more than ten years ago and
Trump has gotten older as we all have
and hopefully wiser and we haven't heard
anything in over a decade about about
any activities like that you know when
you see Melania and Trump together as
I've seen them together many times at
merrill ago there's no way they could
cover up a bad relationship they have
these intense conversations discussions
my wife Pam and I saw them at merrill
ago just before New Year's even also at
the Newseum party which I described
that's worth the price of the book and
and and they laugh and they tease with
each other it is very very charming from
Conover North Carolina Brad go ahead I
just wanted to know why
Tromp made fun of a handicapped guy why
he'd been a little John McCain why he
told Howard Stern that his Vietnam was
trying not to catch an STD when he got
five deferments and sure he should hand
out hundred-dollar bills to the janitor
because he's he's crapped a lot of
people out of the money why can't he get
a loan in the u.s. why does he have to
go to Ducie Bank or something like that
to get a loan and and I don't know on
and on with the guy he's a phony he's
not like you say he he probably is not
worth 11 billion dollars like he says he
might not even be worth a billion okay
thanks Brian yeah some of those comments
make me cringe I have not met a trump
supporter who does not say the same
thing and it's part of his stick to get
publicity he wrote in the art of the
deal even bad publicity is is good
because it draws attention to me and
that's the that's the way he operates
it's Donald Trump then aware about his
actions of what it does to the office of
the presidency overall an interesting
question he obviously is not concerned
about that he's more concerned about
results and that I think is what he will
be remembered for decades from now we
won't remember the tweets we won't
remember the comments that make us
cringe we'll remember the effect of the
tax cuts in boosting the economy the the
stock market getting rid of Isis safer
America and that's the way presidents I
remember the same with Reagan totally
made fun of by the media and years later
a lot of the top media people have
admitted they were wrong about him and
in fact the Gallup poll found that he
was the most the greatest US president
according to this particular poll Sheila
is in Far Rockaway New York independent
line hello how are you this morning
fine thank you go ahead
always interesting conversations going
on here the statement he made about him
bringing up the employment of African
Americans that was happening already and
the regulating didn't make that happen
you don't even know what they
deregulated so I don't you know and
you're a friend you're a very good
friend of his so there's bias with
everyone you know everything you're
saying about him is good and you make
the comments about President Obama you
know like he didn't do anything
he got to Wars housing collapse Wall
Street falling people losing jobs before
with with President Bush it took him
eight years against a Congress that
never even helped him he walked into a
situation that was already rising okay
thanks Sheila yeah if you read the book
you see that even though I am a friend
of Trump I acted as a journalist because
over and over again
I have criticism I have negative items
and there's no way that I was trying to
do a puff piece because by definition a
puff piece has to have everything
positive the unemployment rate is
unprecedented that means that even
though there were improvements under
Obama and then some down dips never
before in recorded history has the
unemployment rate been this low so those
are those are real facts and I think
over time people will start to recognize
that you know wow this economy is great
where you have jobs we're safer and they
will start to recognize that Trump
really has brought results Republican
line from Kentucky dan go ahead I hope
you mention the books quite a few times
a title because sometimes I get on there
and I miss the title of books I don't
know what the title of books are but I
was wanting to know how he felt about
the you know investigation and you know
you said you creams while we're going
you hear them
that's called complaining whining all
that I don't crayon I
I caught the company line then cuz they
wrote cracked me up you know they just
you know it's just like told about the
passing the bill in the Senate I said
the welding they hold the majority well
51 and you know 51 bolts they still need
nine so you know unless the Democrats
get on board helping mouth it's not like
he's really got the house I mean the
Senate you know so that's why I don't I
don't cringe when they conquer plane
line and wimp I kind of last bite off
just like the tongue meal and I think if
they get on board and helping he could
be the best president in this century
cuz we've already seen the worst and Ron
Tesla with that in mind as the president
said anything or any interviews or did
you ask anybody about the upcoming
midterm elections and particularly what
it might do for the remainder of this
term I didn't get into that with Trump
certainly he believes he's going to be
reelected and again the economy is
number one I think when it comes to
elections and the poles of our
constantly underestimated his his
support so I think he will win I
predicted in a Daily Mail article in
January 2016 that he would win the
presidency that was before he was
nominated so I think I have a pretty
good ability to see around corners
because so you also mentioned the
interview did at mar-a-lago the
president frequently calls the Moller
investigation a hoax he and first of
that did he talk a little bit about that
you know I asked him why did why did he
get so agitated about this investigation
there's there's nothing there and he
said well I just wanted the truth I
think part of his reaction is is again
staging he wants to be the center of
controversy and that enhances his power
you know if he's the number-one topic of
conversation every day the number one
topic in the media foreign leaders when
I meet with him they want to count out
to him you see the result with North
Korea of his of his threats he's always
using the carrot in the state
and that's what he's doing with Putin
he's doing that with the Chinese leader
who just voted for sanctions against
North Korea and in the UN for the first
time now he's he's starting to say that
he may reduce tariffs on auto imports so
already
Trump's threats are paying off you know
you really have to use your intellectual
prowess to separate in your mind what is
going on here
the results versus some of the noise
that is upsetting from time to time
Harris Steve in Ohio independent line
thank you for taking my call I think
people don't really understand his
thought process so how do you ask or
evaluate his thought process from the
standpoint of political versus
non-political emotional versus logical
the various things that go into his
thought process and the fact that he
changes so quickly is he data-driven
versus non data-driven you know he's
like a prizefighter he's always
counterpunching kind of punching and
fainting and bobbing and weaving
so he's unpredictable that keeps people
fixated on him just as they were in The
Apprentice that is the way he operates -
OH - some 40,000 won for Republicans -
OH - semper 80,000 for Democrats and -
OH - some for 88,000 - for independents
you can send us tweets at c-span lwj and
if you want to make comments about this
on our Facebook page Jews at Facebook at
comm / c-span from Virginia this is
Cheryl in Yorktown hi first 45 Trump was
not selected he was not elected he was
chosen - he needs a good PR yes he's not
all bad there are great points that he
had it needs to work on he needs a good
public relations he has to improve on
his appearance improve on his overall
acceptance by people that way people
would be more accepting of those good
points that he has let's start with
taxes the first day he should do release
his taxes and he's not a billionaire
he he will be by the time he leaves
office though that speaking of all of
this trillion dollar budget need to
ensure that he and his name is not
associated with any contracts or any
business dealings as a result of this
budget
remember honesty people do not trust him
aim okay call her Thanks
you know on his net worth forbes does a
very intensive listing as you know of
the net worth of the top billionaires
and Trump does release his internal
figures to forbes when they do their
accounting and and they're very tough
and and they do list them as as having
threw over three billion dollars in net
worth you know all you have to do is
look at his buildings they exist he
obviously built them with some money a
lot of these things are so obvious just
like Michael Wolf's claim that Trump
didn't want to be President and he
looked like a ghost on election night
Melania didn't want him to run even
though she actually was the one who
urged him to run and she was in tears on
election night all he did was look and
see a TV and when when the wolf is book
says that that he can't remember
anything we'll all you have to do is
watch him on TV when he is in a
conference and and of course remembers
everything that he needs to remember I
was reading in your book about his
relationship with the media particularly
how he loves them and yet he depends on
them in some cases even calls directly
to talk to reporters to what extent does
he communicate directly with the medium
you know how does that compare to the
face we see of him attacking the media
well occasionally like every few weeks
he will call a reporter that he likes
such as Maggie Haberman at the New York
Times although she always writes
negative stories and maybe he's wised up
to that by now I don't know but and then
he will frequently have these
conversations attributed to a source in
the White House he knows that that
enhances the importance of the story
it's an exclusive story at the same time
it creates the impression that there are
more leaks in the White House then there
already are and that's not very good you
know in the book I
say that Kellyanne Conway is the
number-one leaker in the white house
when I interviewed her at the at the
White House and it was recorded she
apparently forgot that she was on the
record and she started lambasting Reince
Priebus Jared and Ivanka calling them
leakers calling previous things that
were just obviously untrue and I also
interviewed aides who told me that
they've seen text messages from her to
reporters leaking material she pushed
back against that though well she she
actually didn't deny it she said you
know I'm friends with Jared Ivanka I was
just there for dinner but but she knows
it's on it's on digital digital
recording and that again is not as
harmful because it undermines his agenda
to have these leaks and criticism of
other aides from Cindy in Washington
State go ahead city Iran hi I just
wanted to thank you for being such an
honest look about the president I can't
wait to read it
and I wanted to also say I want to read
Jeremie drone course use book it sounds
really good but I also want to say a
shout out to q and on on 4chan thank you
guys for doing so much I really
appreciate it
so Ron Kessler then with this book
completed because things change so fast
in this White House how do you follow up
on that do you have other interviews
with members of the another interview
with the president you know there was a
Washington Post review over the weekend
it was very favorable and said it's a
trustworthy book but instead of missed
the point it was like this is a history
now the book is actually meant who
really explained this guy for for a long
period of time so it really is not
dependent on the latest development in
the news it goes into all his policies
explains them and the negative aspect as
well and really tries to flesh out with
anecdotes such as I mentioned with
Melania and Tony the butler just how he
thinks how he operates how he makes
decisions why he chose one person or
another person Romney or whatever and so
I think it's a book that's gonna be
lasting
the Trump Whitehouse changing the rules
of the game by author Ronald Kessler
thanks for your time this morning
thank you we'll get another perspective
on the Trump Whitehouse from PBS
Frontline documentary documentaries
Michael Kirk he talks about his latest
project called Trump's takeover we'll
have that conversation up next later on
in the program NASA plans to launch a
new satellite designed to look at
earth-like planets in the solar system
Martin's still one of the missions Maine
scientists will join us for that
conversation this is Washington journal
continues
[Music]